estos soldados ucranianos patrullan una
aldea cerca de la ciudad de bakmuth
pertenecen a la unidad Witcher
más tarde
el frente ruso se encuentra Solo dos
kilómetros de estas calles
cada movimiento de tropas es perceptible
y representa una amenaza
One
una escena que hace parte de la batalla
por bakmut la más Sangrienta de la
guerra hasta el momento según el
presidente ucraniano bolo de lensky a
pocos días del aniversario de la
invasión Rusia necesita resultados y la
conquista de bacmut es uno de los
principales objetivos en el frente
Oriental
[Música]
ruso Wagner preveía tomar Back muta en
diciembre el año pasado pero la
descoordinación entre el kremlin y la
milicia retrasó hacia la ciudad los
rusos planean conquistar Bad mood en
marzo o abril
la ayuda armamentística de la otan ha
equilibrado las fuerzas en bakmut según
el comandante de la brigada 45 de
artillería ucraniana el 50% del
armamento que Ucrania dispone
actualmente ya es occidental más
sofisticado que el soviético usado por
Rusia
las fuerzas rusas intentan avanzar todos
los días
pero funcionan de manera caótica no
tenemos pérdidas
cosmar nombre de guerra este soldado
batalla 176 kilómetros de backmuth en
copians
a pesar de su entusiasmo las noticias no
son buenas para Ucrania aquí el
Ministerio de defensa ruso se atribuye
nuevas victorias en dirección a jarkid
la más reciente
los residentes de la zona en guerra
desde 2014 solo quieren una cosa vivir
en paz